Welcome back.
I will now introduce you to the
concept of-- well, I've
introduced what vectors are, but
I'll introduce you to how
they can be even more useful and
we're going to use that to
actually solve 2-dimensional
projectile motion problems.
Now we can introduce the game
where you just don't throw the
ball straight up, you can see
how far you can throw the ball
or what's the optimal angle
to throw the ball at.
So hopefully, you'll find this
even more fun, if you can
imagine it, then the
1-dimensional projectile motion.
So everything we've been doing
so far, hopefully, you have an
intuition that the difference
between a vector and a scalar
is that a vector
has direction.
So a vector has-- let me do
colon instead-- has magnitude
and direction.
While a scalar has
only magnitude.
An example of a vector,
velocity is a vector.
That's easy.
Maybe we'll start with v, but
velocity is a vector.
Well in those examples we were
doing before, we said that the
ball was going-- sometimes we
said that the final velocity
was minus 30 meters
per second.
And so where was the magnitude
and what was the direction?
Well, the magnitude was 30.
And the direction was-- I knew
what the direction was by the
sign of that minus sign.
In that same problem, if someone
asked me, what is the
speed of the ball right before
it hits the ground?
I would've said oh, the speed is
just 30 meters per second.
And I wouldn't have to say 30
meters per second down or
minus 30 per second.
I'd just say 30 meters
per second
because that's its speed.
I don't know what direction
it's going in that speed.
So that's its speed.
And in a general way, in one
dimension, you could say that
the scalar of the same quantity
tends to be the
absolute value of the
vector quantity.
Because in this example the
speed is just the absolute
value of this.
If my initial velocity was
plus-- that's not equal,
that's actually just equal.
If the initial velocity was
plus 30 meters per second,
then the speed would still
be 30 meters per second.
So I just wanted to introduce
that notion.
And in one dimension, velocity
can kind of be-- direction can
be implied by positive
or negative numbers.
But now, when we go into two
dimensions, we're going to
have to get a little bit more
sophisticated in terms of how
we give direction.
So let me clear this.
Let me give an example
where I take a ball.
I take a green ball, clearly a
green ball, and I throw it--
this is a straight line.
I throw it at 10 meters per
second, but I don't throw it
straight up.
I actually throw it at a-- let
me think of a good angle.
I throw it at a--
I don't know.
I throw it at a 45
degree angle.
Or if you like, radians,
that's what?
So that's pi, pi over 4.
Let's say I throw it at
a 45 degree angle.
So now my problem becomes
a lot more complicated.
One, how do I specify the
magnitude and direction?
And then, how do I solve
this problem?
How do I figure out how high
it goes, how far it goes.
et cetera.
And hopefully, that's what we
will be able to teach you over
the course of the next
couple of videos.
This is the ground, right?
So one, if I just want to give
the speed and direction, or
the magnitude and the direction
for this vector
quantity, I have just
specified it.
You know, I could to say my
velocity or my initial
velocity is 10 meters per second
at 45 degrees to the
horizon or something
like that.
So that would be a legitimate
velocity specification.
But it's kind of hard to deal
with, so what I'm going to
teach you is something very
neat about vectors.
Is that you can actually break
up a vector into-- I don't
want to introduce two
complicated terms, but into
its orthogonal components.
So you can say well, something
moving at 10 meters per second
at this angle, is actually
moving at some speed upwards
and it's moving at some speed,
in this case, to the right.
Let's say in the positive
direction.
So if you imagine this
coordinate axis, it's moving
in the y direction at some speed
and it's moving in the x
direction at some speed.
And when they're combined at
some way, you get this angle
or you're moving at kind
of an incline.
So how do I figure out-- if I
have 10 meters per second and
I'm moving-- how do I break
that down into my vertical
speed and my horizontal speed?
And I'll show you that it's
actually pretty cool.
It's pretty straightforward.
What you can do is you can
actually draw a vector where
the length of the vector
is its magnitude.
Let's draw it again.
So let's say this is a
coordinate axis and that the
length of this line
right here is 10.
The length of the this line is
10 and it represents speed or
velocity at this point.
And we know this angle
is 45 degrees.
So it turns out that the
vertical component of the
ball's velocity would be
equivalent to the length of
this side, and the horizontal
component would be equivalent
to the length of this side.
This arrow right here is the
same thing as this arrow, I
just translated it
to the right.
Just so that you see that
it's just a triangle.
And it's just not any triangle,
it's a right triangle.
And what's useful-- I don't want
to get too complicated
with linear algebra.
But it's important that the
two directions that you're
breaking it up in are-- well,
they don't have to be, but it
makes it useful that they are at
right angles to each other
because then we can start to use
a lot of our trig ratios.
So let's just figure
out this problem.
I think you just need to
see a lot of example.
So we're going 10 meters per
second at 45 degrees.
Well, what speed am I going
straight up then?
What is the straight up
component of this 10 meters
per second?
Well, how do we figure out this
side if this was just a
regular triangle?
If this is the hypotenuse,
this is
opposite and this is adjacent.
So let me break out
some trigonometry.
soh cah toa.
And if you don't remember your
trig or you never learned
trig, I encourage you to go
watch the trig videos that we
have. soh cah toa.
Which of the trig ratios involve
the opposite and the
hypotenuse?
So our sine.
And we know that sine of theta
is equal to opposite over
hypotenuse.
So we know that the sine of 45
degrees is equal to-- let's
call this my velocity
of vertical.
I've never seen that variable
used in actual physics
classes, but I think
it makes sense.
This is the velocity vertical
and this is the velocity
horizontal.
And later I'll introduce more
conventional conventions, but
that'll do us for now.
So my vertical velocity, the
velocity that I'm going
straight up is-- well, sine of
45 degrees is my vertical
velocity over my kind of
angled velocity, this
hypotenuse over 10.
And what's my horizontal
velocity?
And so if I were to solve for
vertical velocity, I'd get
vertical velocity is
equal to 10 times
the sine of 45 degrees.
And then similarly, my
horizontal velocity, this is
the adjacent over hypotenuse--
cah.
So it's cosine.
So I could say cosine of 45
degrees is equal to my
horizontal velocity over 10.
Or my horizontal velocity is
equal to 10 times the cosine
of 45 degrees.
I'm about to run out of time, so
I'm going to continue this
in the next video.